Nếu như một bà tháng mời, tại chúng tâm chính là 415 trang tiền, Hà Nội.
Báo thị thào và văn hoa, thông tình xã Việt Nam,
phối hợp các đơn vị liên quan tổ chức lấy chào dài buổi sinh phái,
vì tình yêu Hà Nội lên thứ 415 ngày khu trang 2 15.
Năm nay, dài thử ổ lớn, vì tình yêu Hà Nội được chào cho nhà sĩ trình tiến,
người đã để lại dấu ấn đặc biệt trong biệt ở nhà Việt Nam đường đại.
Những các khúc nổi tiến như, nấu hưởng xong hồng, nấu hưởng phố, phố mèo,
mặt trời bé con, quyền nhà đã trở thành dòng trải kiếc,
các hoạm một thàn nổi vừa thân quên vừa thống đống và nhoa.
Sau mệt tắm, mùa dài, dài thử buổi sinh phái đã trở thành một trong những sự kiến
và nhoa có ý tiến hàng đầu, hàng định sức sống bên bị của tình yêu Hà Nội trong sáng tạo
nghệ thật và đổi sống xã hội.
Hà Nội qua em nhà, khuôi hoa, xân khấu, kiến chút, bấn là mạnh mùen bất tật,
nơi chuyển thống và hiện đại hoa quyết, tạo nên bản sắc diện không thể trụ lấn.
Và dài thử buổi sinh phái chính là mính chính xong độ cho sự nối dài của giống trẻ kiếc ếc,
qua mỗi năm, mối tắc phẩm, mối con người.